.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Die Medien möchten gerne
etwas Privates von uns.
Privat nennt sich privat,
weil es privat ist.
Alles, was privat ist,
ist nicht öffentlich.
Wenn es öffentlich ist,
ist es nicht mehr privat.
Wenn ihr mich privat filmen würdet,
würde ich ins Kissen furzen
und mit schlecht sitzender Unterhose
in der Küche rumlungern,
und die Milch würde überkochen.
Das will ich nicht zeigen.
Aber das wäre privat.
Wenn man mich früher als Kind
so behandelt hätte,
wie man Kinder heute behandelt,
hätte man mir Ritalin gegeben.
Ich wäre kein Clown geworden.
Man hätte mich ruhiggestellt,
mit dieser Energie.
Aber diese Energie ist super.
Wenn ich etwas mache, dann ganz.
Ich kann ganz schlecht aufgeben.
Wenn ich nicht weiss,
warum eine Tür nicht aufgeht,
klopfe ich lange an die Tür.
Und ...
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Das trifft bei mir zu.
Ich glaube fest daran,
dass alles irgendwie möglich ist.
Das ist eine grosse Frage,
wenn man sich fragt,
was wichtig ist.
Schon als Jugendlicher habe ich mich
mit der Sinnfrage schwergetan,
mit der Frage, was das alles soll.
* Ruhige, zauberhafte Musik *
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Ursus and Nadeschkin
with the fastest show
you've ever seen.
Unser Anfangsbild.
* Kurze Musikeinspielung *
* Hupe *
* Schnelle Zirkusmusik *
Okay. - Drei, vier ...
(Gleichzeitig) Es erwarten Sie
Künstler aus aller Welt.
Ich bin Ursus ...
- Ich bin Nadeschkin.
Ich mache die Frau im Programm.
Man kann darauf hinweisen ...
Ich bin Ursus. Wir sind zu zweit.
- Das reicht.
Ich bin in Zürich aufgewachsen
und lustig.
Wer bist du denn?
Wer bist denn du?
Wir sind nach langer Zusammenarbeit
mental brutal kongruent.
Synchron sprechen ist nicht schwer.
(Beide)
Du sprichst mir immer alles nach.
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
(Beide) Ä-rö-tö-rö.
Maus, Katze, Bär, Zebra, Streifen.
Äh!
Ja.
- Nein.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Das neue Programm
von Ursus & Nadeschkin:
"Tanz der Zuckerpflaumenfähre".
Heute wird das Programm
zum ersten Mal vor Publikum gezeigt.
Eine Testvorstellung.
Die erste von insgesamt 18.
Machen wir es noch mal langsam?
Damit es total ist.
(Wir haben uns
auf die Woche hier gefreut.)
(Wir sind im Chössi Theater
im Toggenburg.)
(Es ist quasi eine Camp-Woche.)
(Wir sind noch ... Wir wussten,
dass wir noch nicht weiter sind.)
(Das auszuhalten, ist schwierig.)
Ich kann auch vorne.
* Wirre Glockenklänge *
(Heute erwartet uns der erste Test
von viel Material.)
(Wir haben es in eine
sinnvolle Reihenfolge gebracht.)
(Wir haben die Spur
eines roten Fadens.)
* Spannende Musik, Klirren von Glas *
Wir treiben die Herde zusammen.
Man kann zuschauen. Einige Schafe
erkennt man, andere nicht.
(Ich bin erstaunt,
dass ich nicht nervöser bin.)
(Es ist eine Aufgabe,
die gar nicht geht.)
Aber es hat auch etwas Beruhigendes,
wenn man sieht ...
Es klappt sowieso nicht.
Wir sind gespannt.
Wir schauen, was doch klappt
oder was wie nicht klappt.
Genau.
* Unverständlicher Sprechgesang *
Panna cotta. Das kenne ich. Lecker.
Tom Ryser ist nicht nur Regisseur.
Als Co-Autor entwickelt er gemeinsam
mit Nadja und Urs die Stücke.
(Ursus & Nadeschkin
waren schon immer Botschafter.)
(Man mag sie als Figuren.)
(Man glaubt sie zu verstehen.)
(Man liebt sie auch dafür -
Urs mit seinem verschrobenen Humor,
Nadeschkin
mit ihrem leichten Anarchismus ...)
(Die Figuren sind gute Türöffner.)
"Komm mit. Du verstehst das.
Komm mit uns mit."
"Wir verstehen es auch nicht ganz,
aber wir erkunden es gemeinsam."
* Sanfte, zauberhafte Musik *
* Sie lacht. *
(Lachend) Statt mit ...
Statt mit einem Pfau
kaufen wir dir einen Zug
und benennen es nach dir.
Das ist aber lieb.
Genau.
* Indisch klingender,
unverständlicher Gesang *
Uh-ah!
* Indisch klingender,
unverständlicher Gesang *
Du bist einfach zu schnell.
Stopp.
Es bringt mich draus.
- Das üben wir in dieser Probe.
Ich bin zu schnell. Gut. Noch mal.
Sorry.
Sag einfach: "Du bist zu schnell."
Ich habe lauter gespielt
und höre es weniger.
Ich bin Schlagzeuger.
- Ja.
Nur ganz schnell.
- Ich muss schneller werden.
Okay. Go!
(Wir haben alle schon Türen geknallt
und uns angebrüllt.)
(Wir haben schon geweint, waren
verzweifelt, wollten aufhören.)
# Uo-uo-uo-uo.
(Und, ganz wichtig. Das habe ich
früh von ihnen gelernt:
am Abend immer Frieden schliessen.)
(Bevor man nach Hause geht,
schliesst man Frieden.)
(Jeden Abend.)
* Indisch klingender Gesang *
Wir zeigen heute Sachen,
die noch nicht stimmen.
Und Texte, die schön wären,
wenn man sie richtig liefern würde.
Aber ich kann nicht so schnell
lernen. Wir schreiben jetzt noch um.
Wir schauen, wie ihr reagiert auf
das, was wir meinen, was lustig ist.
Also: Lacht richtig!
Hinten wird gemessen.
Es beginnt super. Dann kommen
Sachen, die wir nicht wissen.
Und den Rest wissen wir auch nicht.
Ich dachte, Madonna sei im Publikum.
- Was? Wo?
Dort. Sie dort.
Wo?
- Zweite Reihe.
Madonna?
Hi. Can I have an Autogramm?
Sie ist es nicht.
- Das ist der Hammer.
Die sieht privat brutal anders aus.
- Ja, aber ...
* Gemächliche Musik *
Ursus & Nadeschkin
fliegen nach Edinburgh.
Es ist eine Reise
zurück zu ihren Anfängen.
Schon in jungen Jahren
sind sie im englischsprachigen Raum
vor kleinem Publikum aufgetreten.
Jetzt, viele Jahre später,
wagen sie dieses Abenteuer erneut.
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Wir können abstürzen,
es kann nicht funktionieren,
es kann uns niemand
interessant oder lustig finden.)
(Aber das Schöne ist, dass wir
tun können, was wir wollen.)
(Wir haben grossen Freiraum.
Niemand erwartet etwas.)
(Das ist extrem befreiend.)
(Das suchen wir immer wieder.)
(In der Schweiz
kriegen wir das nicht mehr.)
Normalerweise
ist das Wetter nicht so schön.
Das stimmt nicht.
Du sagst das zwar immer.
Ich finde, es regnet ständig.
Schau dir das an! Alles nass.
Darum ist es so schön grün.
Das ist das Klavier.
Dieses Klavier
habe ich noch nie gebraucht.
Wir haben es mitgenommen,
damit Urs es nicht braucht.
Und er braucht es oft nicht.
Erstaunlich,
wie oft man es nicht brauchen kann.
Es steht immer nur im Weg.
- Es brauchte viel Platz im Bus.
Es war ein heikler Transport.
Das Edinburgh Festival Fringe
in Schottland
ist das grösste Kulturfestival
weltweit.
Täglich gibt es über 2'000
Aufführungen an 317 Spielstätten.
Die Konkurrenz ist gross.
Vier Wochen lang
haben Ursus & Nadeschkin
täglich einen Auftritt
auf ihrer kleinen Bühne.
Ein Meerschweinchen.
(Wir sind gewappnet, dass
die erste Woche schwierig wird.)
(Wir werden streiten
oder deprimiert sein.)
(Wenige Leute werden kommen.)
(Aber wenn dann nichts passiert,
ist es das Schlimmste.)
(Etwas muss gehen. Sonst halten wir
die vier Wochen nicht durch.)
With 15 people we will have one row.
# I wanna be loved by you just you.
* Geräuschvolles Einatmen *
# Nobody else but you.
* Quietschen *
* Popmusik *
(Beide) We hope you have a good time
and enjoy the show.
* Sie sprechen gleichzeitig zwei
verschiedene Texte auf Englisch. *
(Beide) We hope you have a good time
and enjoy the show.
Yes. Thank you.
Das Publikum hat nie geklatscht.
Man kam sich ...
Es war ganz schlimm.
Das nennt man Dead End.
Das ist ...
- ... Englisch.
Sackgasse. Morgen aufhören.
Nie mehr.
Have one.
- For the collection.
For you.
* Schwermütige Musik *
Warte. Schau hier.
"Synchronschwimmen -
die Trockenversion".
Was spüren Sie, wenn Sie das sehen?
- Hier hängen viele Plakate.
Und für einmal auch unseres.
Hat er dir schon gesagt,
dass wir heute ...
- Ich glaube, alle wissen es.
Alle wissen es.
- Es ist ... nicht mehr lustig.
Meine Güte!
- Die anderen haben 16 Tage.
Ja, aber wir haben 15.
* Beide lachen. *
Auf der Toilette hat es mehr Leute.
* Rasante Musik *
I think we never had such
a small crowd for the whole run.
Ja, for the whole ...
No. Since 1989 I think.
That's actually a record.
- Yeah. It's a recod.
It's not a joke, isn't it?
- No, it's not a joke.
Let's say Hallo personally.
Good to see you.
- Hello. That's nice.
Normally we have 70 people.
We could never do this.
Are swiss people in tonight?
- (Mehrere) Ja.
One, two, three ... - I thought,
we perform here in secret.
Don't tell them back home.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie es wäre,
wenn es voll wäre.
Am Sonntag
hatten wir einen Kurzauftritt.
Dort funktionierten Sachen,
die jetzt nicht klappen,
weil es zu wenig Leute sind.
Am Ende möchte ich jeweils
gleich nach Hause.
Ja, das ist super.
- Wir nehmen nur die Kostüme mit.
Gut.
- Aber sag mal.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Was?
- Es ist nass. Regnet es hier rein?
Na toll! - "Synchronised Swimming:
The Dry Version", heisst es.
(Wir mögen Probleme oder Dinge,
die im Weg sind.)
(Denn das bringt uns weiter.)
Irgendwann macht man es sich cozy
in der Comfort Zone.
Alles ist gut. Zu gut.
Aber nein.
Zwischendurch muss es Reibung geben.
Wir wollen Grenzen spüren.
Und das können wir hier wieder.
Ging das für einige, unter dem Haus
durchzurennen? Saubere Sache.
Tom Ryser arbeitet als Regisseur
für verschiedenste Produktionen
in ganz Europa.
Hier z.B. in Bremen für die Oper
"Das Horoskop des Königs, L'etoile".
* Schnelle Klaviermusik *
(Tom Ryser ist unser Regisseur
seit 28 Jahren.)
(Nein, seit 30 Jahren.)
(Oder seit 75 Jahren.
Er war es immer schon.)
(Wir hatten
immer nur Tom als Regisseur.)
(Er ist unser Schiedsrichter,
unser Psychologe, unser ...)
(... unser Freund.)
- (Unser Therapeut.)
(Unser Masseur.)
- (Unser Sportlehrer.)
(Unser Stimmlehrer.)
(Wir sind eigentlich ein Trio.)
(Wir könnten uns nicht vorstellen,
mit jemand anderem zu arbeiten.)
(Wir müssten wieder weit hinten
anfangen mit einem neuen Regisseur.)
(Und wir würden oft denken:
"Ach, wäre Tom noch hier.")
("Der wüsste, was wir meinen.")
# Erschiessen.
Äh!
(Wir haben die Regelung: Wenn ich
bei ihnen bin, bin ich es ganz.)
(Wenn ich weg bin,
bin ich ganz weg.)
* Unverständlicher Sprechgesang *
(Wenn ich weg bin,
bin ich ganz weg.)
(Wenn es brennt, komme ich sofort.)
Aber in solchen Phasen bin ich
weit weg von Ursus & Nadeschkin.
* Überdrehter Chorgesang *
Wir gehen in den Halbkreis.
(Grundsätzlich mag ich es.
So viele Leute auf der Bühne.)
(Ich hätte gerne noch mehr Leute.)
(Die Arbeit ist einfacher
mit einer riesigen Gruppe.)
(Man kriegt andere Resultate.)
Nein, doch, oh, uh.
(Der grösste Unterschied ist,
dass ich in einem Apparat
wie einem Staatstheater oder
Opernhaus immer das Gefühl habe,
ich arbeite gegen die Zeit.)
(Es sind viele Leute.
Und dann ist noch die Technik.)
(Das ist der grösste Unterschied.)
Bei Ursus & Nadeschkin
bringt mir niemand was.
Ich habe keine Assistentin,
die alles liest.
Keine Hospitantin,
die alles aufschreibt.
Keine Bühnenbildassistentin,
die alles bringt und holt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nach zwei Wochen in Edinburgh hoffen
Ursus & Nadeschkin noch immer darauf,
endlich einmal
vor vollem Haus zu spielen.
Wenn wir es schon testen,
dann richtig.
Und gefährlich.
It's easy
to connect it up the wrong way.
And then ... you don't want to know.
* Rasseln *
* Klingeln *
Three, two, one ...
* Leiser Knall *
"Hä? Woher hast du den Ballon?",
muss ich sagen.
"Dabei habe ich ihn aufgeblasen."
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Wir flyern die ganze Zeit.)
- (Immer).
(Ich flyere nur nicht,
wenn ich aufs WC muss.)
(Wir sind neu hier.)
(Wir müssen alles auf jeder Ebene
machen, um Leute zu erreichen.)
(Wir wussten, dass wir hier
wieder bei null anfangen
und uns
in eine andere Zeit zurückwerfen.)
(Aber es ist auf vielen Ebenen ...)
(Ein kleines Publikum,
Leute, die uns nicht kennen ...)
(Wir müssen uns
nach Publikum abstrampeln.)
(Es sind viele Sachen. Flashbacks.)
(Beide) Dum-tschäggä.
Dum-tschäggä. Dum-tschäggä.
* Ulkige Musik *
* Schnelle Musik *
Ja, klar. Ich war es wieder.
(Wie haben wir uns kennengelernt?)
(Nadja ist aus Zürich. Grossstadt.
Ich bin aus Aarau.)
Ich war ein Jahr älter.
- Ja, genau.
Wir haben uns nicht gekannt. Zuerst.
- Nein.
Aber ich wollte Zirkus machen
in den Sommerferien.
Es gibt Kurse, die fast gratis sind.
- Von Jugi Tours organisiert.
Zwei Wochen Ferienlager
in Wiesbaden, ein Zirkuskurs.
Dort haben wir uns beide angemeldet.
Wir sahen uns das erste Mal ...
- Seine Mutter hat ihn angemeldet.
Ich habe mich angemeldet. Aber meine
Mutter hat mich darauf hingewiesen.
* Rasante Trommelschläge *
(Dann waren wir
in diesem Zirkuskurs.)
(Das war ein sehr schlechter,
aber rührend organisierter Kurs.)
(Es hiess, man lerne dort alles.)
(Zauberei, Akrobatik,
Jonglieren, Breakdance, alles.)
(Bei verschiedenen Lehrern und so.)
(Dann war es ein Lehrer.
Ein alternder Rumäne.)
(Der Zirkus war ein Raum,
in dem Requisiten waren.)
(Keine 20 m2.)
- (Er sagte: "Macht einfach!")
(Er hat uns nichts gelehrt.)
(Und es gab
seltsame Kursteilnehmer.)
(Dann kam dieser filmreife Moment.)
(Davon erzählen wir
immer wieder gerne.)
Etwa nach fünf Tagen
wurde dieser ... - Dumitru.
- ... Dumitru vom ZDF angerufen.
"ZDF Fernsehgarten".
- Diese Sonntagmorgen-Show.
Die hatten das Thema Zirkus.
Sie wollten, dass wir
ein wenig Background für sie machen.
Da sagte Dumitru natürlich Ja.
Er wollte
seine Zirkusschule berühmt machen.
Dann bemerkte er aber,
dass Sommerferien sind.
Da waren nur
diese blöden Kursteilnehmer ...
... die noch nichts können.
Er rief uns zusammen und sagte, wir
müssten drei Tage später nach Mainz.
Einer konnte zaubern.
Der hat gezaubert.
Einige konnten das Rad schlagen.
Die machten Akrobatik.
Alle konnten etwas,
nur wir zwei nicht.
Wir waren noch übrig.
Da sagte er: "Prr."
Dann nahm er vom Fenstersims
zwei Clownnasen und sagte:
"Ihr seid Clowns."
Er sagte: "Ihr könnt nichts.
Ihr macht die Clowns."
(Wir gingen jeden Samstag ...)
(Ich war noch im Gymnasium,
Urs in der Lehre.)
(Wir gingen jeden Samstag an
die Seepromenade und traten auf.)
(Wir übten eine Nummer ein -
mit Musik und Jonglieren.)
(Wir hatten
drei Musikkassetten dabei.)
Wir wollten das
drei Monate lang machen.
Die drei Monate.
- Und dann ist wieder fertig.
Urs ist gut im Aufhören.
- Ich wollte immer aufhören.
Eigentlich auch heute noch.
- Ja.
Wenn du mir gesagt hättest,
dass wir das 31 Jahre lang ...
32 Jahre.
Ich hätte gedacht, du spinnst.
V.a. mit ... dir.
* Sie trällern ulkige Musik mit. *
Digä-dägä-digä-dägä ...
She sells sea shells
by the sea shore.
Any swiss people in here tonight?
Oh, one, two, three, four, five.
Wow. Together with us ... seven.
Switzerland
must be half empty tonight.
* Rasante Musik *
You are so clever.
It's stunning. Beautiful.
That's so nice.
Because we are very much ...
... sometimes questioning ourselves.
Because sometimes people are hard.
- It is difficult.
* Klare, klingelnde Musik *
Wenn das jemand filmen würde ...
Das wäre
die klassische Rollenverteilung.
Die Frau näht, der Mann macht Sport.
Das würde aber nie jemand filmen.
- Nein, ich glaube auch nicht.
Ich meine ...
* Sie lacht. *
Was machst du eigentlich?
Meine Naht ...
Das ist die schlimmste Vorstellung.
Man steht auf der Bühne und die Naht
an der Pobacke geht auf. Hinten.
Grüezi, Nadja.
- (Lachend) Nein.
Nein.
Okay. Ja.
Was machst du hier? - Ich
geniesse das Sofabett backstage.
Ist das backstage?
- Ja.
Es gibt eine Open-Air-Lounge.
Was machst du jetzt?
* Knallen und Scheppern *
* Explosion *
* Metallisches Scheppern *
Gegen Ende
spüren die beiden mehr und mehr,
dass sich das Wagnis gelohnt hat.
Die Zuschauer
sind nun doch neugierig geworden.
Der schönste Lohn für die beiden.
Gestern hatten wir unsere erste
Sold-out-Show. Wir sind happy.
Am Morgen waren es acht
verkaufte Tickets. Am Abend 120.
We hope you have a good time
and enjoy the show.
But more than that we hope you ...
differalt cultural area ...
Cultural area. Cultural.
Caltschural. Ein schwieriges Wort.
Hello. It's me.
* Sie lacht. *
(Es ist cool:
Wenn man auf Englisch auftritt,
sollte man es auf verschiedenen
Bühnen ausprobieren.)
(Das ist eine grosse Bühne
mit 250 oder 350 Leuten.)
Für Schweizer Verhältnisse nicht
so gross, aber für uns hier schon.
Man kann
einen anderen Rhythmus ausprobieren.
Und wir wollen v.a. Leute haben,
damit wir nachher flyern können.
* Schnauben *
* Stöhnen *
* Hauchen *
(Beide) Was? Ja, ja, ja.
No, no, no.
Hä?
Oh, hm. Was? Danke.
Hm. Ja, ja.
* Schnalzen *
Thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
Ich fühle mich
ein wenig ausgemergelt.
Jeder Tag ist ... hm ... jetzt ...
Dann hängt es vom Wetter ab
oder den Leuten,
die man trifft, die Energie geben.
* Ruhige, besinnliche Musik *
(Es lief erstaunlich gut.)
(Es gab viele Aufs und Abs.)
(Es ist
ein sehr unberechenbares Festival.)
(Das hat sich bis zum Schluss
nicht geändert.)
(Wir haben immer davon gelebt,
dass wir sehr unterschiedlich sind.)
(Schon 2 Std.
nach unserem Kennenlernen
hatten wir unseren ersten Konflikt.)
(Das ist gut. Wenn man so anfängt,
weiss man: Das gehört zu uns.)
Da könnte man ganz nach oben.
(Ein Konflikt heisst nicht,
dass man sich nicht versteht.)
(Man versteht nur
die andere Ansicht noch nicht.)
(Man weiss,
man möchte sich nicht schaden
und zieht letztlich
am selben Strang.)
Dort ist unser Theater.
(Wir wissen beide,
dass es unser beider Anliegen ist,
zu versuchen, weiterzumachen.)
(Aber ... die Trennung
steht jedes Jahr im Raum.)
* Lachen im Publikum *
(Wir machten irgendwann sogar
ein Stück, ein wichtiges Stück
zum Thema Trennung/Solo.)
Okay. Ta!
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.
(Wir wussten schon immer,
dass wir sehr unterschiedlich sind.)
(Wir haben ganz klar
eigene Universen und eigene Wege,
die sich überschneiden,
aber nicht nur.)
(Darum haben wir "SOLO!"
darauf aufgebaut.)
(Die Idee von "SOLO!" war:
Ich habe um 20 Uhr ein Soloprogramm
auf dieser Bühne,
und Nadja hat ein Soloprogramm -
blöderweise,
schlecht geplant auch um 20 Uhr,
auch auf dieser Bühne.)
Zwei mit komplett anderen Programmen
prallen aufeinander.
Der Abend lebte davon.
Während ich da hinten sitze und
professionell Präsenz markiere ...
Aber nein, wer kommt da?
Der singende Nudelauflauf.
Natürlich.
Wollten Sie sich noch was sagen?
Denn jetzt wäre zu spät.
So. Entschuldigung. Das ist eine
dehnbare amerikanische Magenwand.
So. Jetzt wird es viel familiärer.
Das ist das Schauspielhaus,
kein Kleintheater.
# ... kriegsch ä Tritt,
ich bi fit, wänn ich nur wett.
# Min Sprit längt au für dich mit.
Häsch de Ziit, bin i zwiit ...
# ... Pommes Frites, Chlöpfshit,
Usziit, gliich vill zwiit. Wenn ...
# Han mich total im Text verloffe,
ha s'Wort nüm gfunde.
(Ich konnte Edinburgh
nicht so recht geniessen.)
(Ich hatte sozusagen
eine Lebenskrise.)
(Ich hatte schlechte Blutwerte.)
(Wir machten eine lange Pause
ohne darauf Rücksicht zu nehmen,
dass wir hätten
abtrainieren müssen.)
(Mein Adrenalinspiegel
war ständig hoch.)
(Ich konnte
kein Adrenalin mehr abbauen.)
(Ich habe abgenommen,
konnte nicht mehr schlafen.)
Ich hatte viele Burnout-Symptome.
Es war aber kein Burnout.
Aber man stellte mich in diese Ecke.
Und natürlich ging in dieser Zeit
noch die Liebe kaputt.
(Nicht der Papa meines Sohnes,
sondern die danach,
von der ich dachte, die hält.)
(Ich vertraute
meinem Neurologen sehr.)
(Der sagte mir: "Du musst schauen,
dass der Adrenalinwert sinkt.")
("Und das schaffst du
am besten mit Spielen.")
(Die Therapie
war eigentlich die Vorstellung.)
Ich habe früh gelernt,
auf jeden Baum zu klettern.
Man muss einfach
ein Seil dabeihaben.
Das Seil wirft man über einen Ast.
So kann man sich selbst hochziehen.
Man muss nicht warten,
bis jemand kommt und hilft.
So kommt man auf jeden Baum.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Noch bevor Ursus & Nadeschkin
nach Edinburgh reisten,
haben sie
eine zweijährige Auszeit genommen.
Urs war mit seiner Familie
auf einer Weltreise und hat
an eigenen Projekten gearbeitet,
u.a. an einem neuen Buch.
Corn Fakes.
Wie tief
ist diese Badewanne für dich?
Die ist vielleicht etwa so hoch.
- Ja.
Vielleicht müsste ich sie
noch flacher machen.
Damit man nicht die Assoziation
einer normalen Badewanne hat.
Nadja hat in ihrer Auszeit
u.a. in Berlin ein Stück
über Obdachlosigkeit entwickelt,
geschrieben und inszeniert.
(Ich fand die Auszeit super.)
(Ich konnte im Leben aufräumen,
mich neu orientieren,
Dinge tun, die ich sonst nicht tue.)
(Ich hatte privat wieder mal Zeit
für Dinge,
die ich sonst immer verpasse.)
Wir haben Platz erhalten für Dinge,
die wir sonst nie machen können.
Eine solche Inszenierung,
ein solches Stück
war für mich eine grosse Chance.
Am GGRIPS Theater trifft Nadja
ihre beiden Schauspieler.
Ich würde mir im Herbst
gerne zwei Tage rausnehmen,
damit wir wieder einmal Zeit haben.
Und vielleicht auch
das eine oder andere rausschmeissen.
Oder eure Erfahrungen einbringen.
Ich dachte immer, dass der Mensch
ein Stück weit selbst schuld
und selbst verantwortlich
für seine Taten ist.
Und ... als wir
das Stück gebaut haben,
musste ich diese Haltung
komplett umbauen.
Es gibt ganz viele,
die es in einer Verkettung
von negativen Erlebnissen
umhaut oder aus dem Leben haut.
Sie funktionieren nicht mehr.
Seit zwei Jahren
läuft das Stück "Aus die Maus"
erfolgreich
am Berliner GRIPS Theater.
Die Show
ist fast jedes Mal ausverkauft.
Entschuldigung.
Ich spiele hier
gerade eine Vorstellung.
Entschuldigung. Ich ...
Ich bin sofort weg. Entschuldigung.
Was habe ich denn gestern gesoffen,
dass ich ...
Das geht nicht. Hier sind Kinder.
- Geht das auch etwas freundlicher?
Mann!
Ich hab doch gesagt,
ich bin gleich weg.
Was glaubst du,
wieso die Kinder gelacht haben?
Weil du ein Stück Scheisse bist.
Habt ihr gelacht,
weil ich ein Stück Scheisse bin?
(Kinder) Nein.
* Rasante Popmusik *
(Die Texte sind nicht
am Schreibtisch entstanden.)
(Das sind reine Improvisationen
aufgrund der Info,
die wir durch die Recherchearbeit
bei den Obdachlosen bekommen haben.)
* Rasante Popmusik *
(Nach dem Stück
gibt es immer ein Gespräch.)
(Die Kinder
haben immer viele Fragen.)
(Sie bekommen Angst, dass
ihnen das auch passieren könnte.)
(Man muss aufpassen,
dass die Kinder keine Angst haben.)
(Wir sagen ihnen,
dass sie Sorge tragen müssen,
dass ihnen das nicht passiert.)
Wir haben auch
mit Obdachlosen getestet.
Ja?
Ja, mit Obdachlosen.
Die fanden das aber viel zu harmlos.
"Was uns auf der Strasse passiert,
was uns gesagt wird,
ist viel schlimmer."
Deshalb lassen wir das
mit dem Stück Scheisse drin.
Auch wenn die Lehrer das
manchmal ein bisschen hart finden.
Aber sie erleben das so.
Es gibt Autofahrer, die halten an
und beschimpfen sie einfach so.
Das ist ein hartes Leben.
Wir dürfen das
auf der Bühne nicht verharmlosen.
Sonst denkt ihr:
"Das ist ja ganz lustig."
Es ist nicht lustig, da zu leben.
* Musik und Gesang
aus "Aus die Maus" *
# Weil es so ist, wie es ist.
# Glaub an dich, bau ein Haus,
denn dann geht es gut aus.
# Das Leben ist schön.
# Und auch morgens um sieben
in den Urlaub zu fliegen.
# Das Leben ist schön.
(Ich war alleine
mit meinem Sohn unterwegs.)
(Ich wollte keine Weltreise
alleine mit einem Achtjährigen -
damals Sechsjährigen - machen.)
(Das wollte ich ihm nicht zumuten.)
(Ich wollte ihm etwas Neues zeigen,
das anders funktioniert.)
(Er hat schnell Hochdeutsch gelernt
und Berlin lieben gelernt.)
(Das war total schön zu sehen.)
(Es war eine gute Entscheidung für
uns als Team - für Sid und mich.)
(Ich habe viel mit ihm über Armut
und die Obdachlosen gesprochen.)
Er stellte diese Fragen:
"Was machen die auf der Strasse?"
"Was ist Geld?"
Er kann noch nicht rechnen.
"Warum geben wir ihm nur
ein paar Euro? Wir haben doch mehr."
Man muss differenzieren
zwischen Obdachlosigkeit
und Armut im Generellen.
Die meisten, die auf der Strasse
leben, wählen das selbst.
Es ist eigentlich
frei gewählte Armut.
Es ist kein Spass.
- Und die Familie?
Tja.
Das hat sich alles
irgendwo zerlaufen.
Es ist so ... Ich habe auch
über 30 Jahre gearbeitet.
Ich habe auch Kinder grossgezogen,
war auch 14 Jahre verheiratet.
Wenn das Glashaus, in dem du sitzt,
irgendwann bröckelt
und du nirgendwo sonst Halt findest,
dann schmierst du ab.
Quasi Paul Klee.
Statistisch geordnet.
Die drei Bücher "Kunst aufräumen"
von Urs Wehrli,
welche seit 2002 erschienen sind,
sind längst
internationale Beststeller.
Sie wurden in 15 Ländern aufgelegt
und allein im deutschsprachigen Raum
über 1 Mio. Mal verkauft.
Es gab Ausstellungen
und Auftritte in ganz Europa,
eine eigene Serie
bei der "Sendung mit der Maus"
und sogar
eine Sonderbriefmarke bei der Post.
Das ist die Versammlung der
Aargauer Gemeindeschreiber/-innen.
Eigentlich
eine trockene Veranstaltung.
Sie haben ihre Generalversammlung -
mit Referenten oder Showacts.
Ich bin ein Showact.
Ursus Wehrli.
Die Idee ist einfach bestechend.
Entwickelt hat er sie u.a.
bei seinen zahlreichen Besuchen
in Kunsthäusern und Galerien.
Hinter dem Applaus steht Arbeit.
Ursus Wehrli
seziert Kopien der Meisterwerke
und ordnet sie neu -
fein säuberlich.
Für seine Kunst
geht Urs Wehrli über ...
Du bist sowieso zu gross.
... Badegäste.
Kurz: Er räumt alles auf,
was ihm in die Quere kommt.
Die waren farblich nicht sortiert.
Ich habe sie dann gebeten,
sich aufzuräumen.
90 Min. dauert der bunte Spass,
bis alle 100 Fahrzeuge in Reih
und Glied stehen. Phu, geschafft.
Ich möchte mich kurz vorstellen.
Mein Name ist Ursus Wehrli.
Ich halte einen Vortrag
zum Thema "Kunst aufräumen".
Sind schon Fragen da zum Referat?
(Bei Pflichtsachen im Alltag
müsste man keine Listen machen.)
Da bin ich aber ganz schlecht.
Ich versäume vieles.
Ich bin chaotisch.
Irgendwie habe ich aber eine Lust,
Dinge zu sortieren oder zu ordnen,
die gar nicht so wichtig sind
oder wo es nicht viel Sinn macht.
Nadja fährt im Kältebus mit -
ein Angebot der Stadtmission Berlin.
Im Winter fahren ehrenamtliche
Mitarbeiter durch die Strassen
und suchen Obdachlose auf.
Diese bekommen Hilfe in Form von
warmen Getränken oder Schlafsäcken.
Oft werden sie auch
zu Notunterkünften gefahren.
Wie viele Notschlafstellen
gibt es denn in Berlin im Winter?
Wisst ihr das?
Es gibt aktuell 1'200 Plätze.
1'200. Und gegen 8'000
sind auf der Strasse.
Die Frage ist, wer in die Statistik
fällt und wer nicht.
Das wissen wir alle
nicht so richtig.
Es gibt ganz grobe Schätzungen.
Kältebus der Berliner Stadtmission.
Hallo.
(Mann am Telefon)
Ich habe jemanden gesehen.
Super. Dann kommen wir da hin. Es
dauert ungefähr eine halbe Stunde.
Wo kommst du her?
Ich komme ... komme ...
... eigentlich aus Deutschland.
Da ich keine leibliche Mutter hatte,
hat mich meine Mutter
dann mit nach Indien genommen.
Ich hoffe,
die haben noch einen Platz für mich.
Wir haben angerufen.
Da ist noch ein Platz frei.
Tschüss.
- Alles Gute. - Tschau.
Wir haben auch so gearbeitet.
Wir sind
bis 1 oder 2 Uhr rumgefahren
und haben dann in der
Notschlafstelle Interviews geführt -
mit Leuten, die wollten.
Geht es weiter? Sind sie voll?
- Nein.
Er hat hier Hausverbot.
- Oh. Okay.
Jetzt kommt
ein kleiner musikalischer Beitrag.
Ähm.
Aber ich brauche noch einen Bogen.
* Lachen im Publikum *
* Applaus *
Soll ich helfen?
- Nein, du machst es kaputt.
* Lachen *
Du sprichst kein Französisch.
Und die Polizei
wollte dich verhaften.
Ich sagte dem Wirt,
es gäbe kein Klopapier.
Wie hast du es gesagt?
Sag's den Leuten!
Ich sagte: "Je suis sans papier."
- Na super!
Nehmen Sie Platz
- Ich stehe lieber.
Speak again, bright angel.
- Das ist ein Chefblatt.
Das ist Mahagoni bis zum Stift rauf.
Bringen Sie Post?
Sie sind so gelb angezogen. - Ruhe!
Sagt der Osterhase zum Schneemann:
"Karotte her oder ich föhne dich."
* Lachen im Publikum *
* Er summt. *
Ich sage einfach:
"Föhn doch du deinen Hobbit."
"Föhn deinen Hobbit selbst" -
oder wie auch immer.
Es ist super.
Im Vergleich zum Solist.
(Wir sind im Kleintheater Luzern.)
Wir haben heute
die zwölfte Testvorstellung.
Wir haben ein Stück.
Es hat ... wie viele Seiten?
Es ist toll. Wir haben ein Stück.
- 34 Seiten.
Wir spielen jetzt noch ein,
zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Mal,
bis wir Premiere haben.
Nur noch? - Das reicht.
- In drei Wochen ist Premiere.
Das ist aber ziemlich cool.
Friends.
(Ein Grund, wieso ich ins Theater
wollte, ist die Familie.)
(Ich habe als Kind
viel Fernsehen geschaut.)
(Es gab immer wieder Sendungen
wie "Stars in der Manege"
oder "Salto Mortale".)
(Dort wird immer gezeigt,
was sie vorne machen
und wie es hinten abgeht,
wie die Familie mitfiebert.)
Diese Sehnsucht hatte ich.
Das wollte ich.
Ich bin nicht wegen des
grossen Erfolgs im Theater gelandet,
sondern weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
da gäbe es eine Familie.)
* Unverständliche Passage
aus der Videoaufnahme *
(Ich werde immer wieder gefragt,
ob wir Freunde sind.)
(Ich weiss nicht, ob wir Freunde
sind, aber wir sind Familie.)
(Ganz klar.
Ich sehe das auch eher so.)
(Wie eine Familienstruktur.
Da kann man auch streiten.)
(In einer Familie stellt man nicht
infrage, dass man verwandt ist
oder zusammengehört.)
(Wir gehören zusammen.)
Und ein Streit oder
eine grössere Auseinandersetzung
tut dem keinen Abbruch.
... vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
Schaut mal, wo ihr seid.
Ihr steht ziemlich gut.
Nadja, noch einen Schritt weiter
nach vorne. Noch einen Schritt.
Noch weiter.
Wenn du normal hochgehst,
machst du so.
Das merkt man am Ende.
Darum bist du immer falsch.
Die Frage ist ... Lassen wir es so,
dass du immer falsch bist?
Warum?
- Du bist immer so anstatt so.
Vor dem hier.
Das ist erst so, seit du dich
beschwert ... Ich muss umlernen.
Und wann lernt man um?
- Wir sind die ganze Zeit dran.
Wenn ich 5 Min. Zeit habe,
lerne ich dauernd Sachen um.
Ich wusste nicht, ob es dir ein
Anliegen ist, das richtig zu machen.
Du musst nicht über mich nachdenken.
- Doch.
Freunde, Entschuldigung.
Das macht ihr beide.
Ihr überlegt immer beide,
was der andere macht.
Und es gibt einen guten Grund dafür.
Ihr seht euch gegenseitig
von aussen.
Dich selbst
siehst du nicht von aussen.
* Sie trällern eine Melodie. *
Ich bin zu weit weg. - Das ist
der letzte Schritt, den ich kann.
Aber der Text ist fertig.
Dann hören die Beine auf.
Du musst dir noch ein Wort denken.
- Mist.
(Es ist anstrengend. Das merke ich
nach einer achtstündigen Probe.)
(Oder nach einer ganzen Woche.)
(Danach bin ich ...)
* Er seufzt. *
(Aber es ist auch sehr befriedigend.
Es ist wunderschöne Arbeit.)
Wenn man es nicht mag, wäre es
sehr anstrengend. Aber wir mögen es.
Ich liebe die Wiederholung.
Ich könnte 100 Std.
an einem Detail feilen.
Nein. Och.
- Och?
Siehst du nicht?
- Nein.
Och.
- Och. - Wir stehen verkehrt. - Ah.
Was, "Ah"?
Ah.
Wir stehen falsch.
Bis wir das verstehen, können wir
1 Std. lang diesen Blödsinn proben.
Wenn du das filmst,
würde das niemand glauben.
Das würde niemand glauben.
- "Spinnen die eigentlich?"
Ich bin froh, dass niemand filmt.
- Und du bringst das "Ah" und "Och".
Das ist typisch. So arbeiten wir.
(Das ist in unserer Arbeit wichtig.)
(Einerseits muss man bei gewissen
Sachen perfekt und akribisch sein.)
(Mit Rhythmen usw.)
(Aber man muss auch loslassen und
das Chaos passieren lassen können.)
(Man muss eintauchen und schauen,
was passiert.)
* Muhen *
Woher hast du die andere?
Die andere hast du.
Das ist die eine.
(Nadja ist eine verrückte Mischung.)
(Sie kann das Chaos perfekt.)
(Sie ist eine ganz andere Anarchie.)
(Es ist schwer zu beschreiben.)
(Sie möchte etwas
auf eine gewisse Art sagen.)
(Wir sagen:
"Das macht keinen Sinn.")
(Mit der Zeit lernt man:
Sie hat recht.)
(Es funktioniert. Eine Energie,
die schwer zu beschreiben ist.)
Sie ist da der unermüdlichste
Mensch, den ich kenne.
Getrieben von ...
... ich weiss nicht welchen Engeln,
Göttern und Teufeln gleichzeitig.
Sie bleibt einfach dran.
Tag und Nacht.
Sie gibt nicht auf. Nie.
Sie hat eine unglaubliche Energie.
Hä? Ja.
Hast du Freude,
auf der Bühne zu sein?
Ja.
Schau mal, dort sind die Leute.
(Urs ist ein Mensch
mit übersteigertem Interesse
an teils unnützen Sachen.)
((Lachend) Eine super Definition.)
(Urs ist ein Mensch, der extrem
gerne in die falsche Ecke schaut.)
(Und er kann extrem gut über
die Dinge lachen, die dort stehen.)
(Er ist
ein extrem herzlicher Mensch.)
(Ein extrem lustiger Mensch.
Er hat einen speziellen Humor.)
Er ist ein sehr spezieller Mensch.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich ihn komplett verstehe.
Er fasziniert mich jeden Tag.
Immer noch. Nach 30 Jahren.
(Seit ich 20 bin,
habe ich Schmerzen.)
(Meine Gelenke sind zu beweglich.)
(Für mich ist Bewegung die Lösung.)
(Wenn ich mich bewege,
spüre ich es nicht.)
(Ich hätte früher
weniger Breakdance machen
und weniger
von Bäumen fallen sollen.)
(Ich wusste nicht,
dass ich Gelenkprobleme habe.)
(Wenn man so beweglich ist,
geht man davon aus,
dass andere das auch haben.)
(Bis 20 tat es auch nicht weh.)
(Ich habe die Slackline gefunden.)
(Wenn ich die Muskeln
mit der Slackline trainiere,
habe ich viel weniger Probleme.)
(Dank der Slackline konnte ich
eine geplante Operation absagen.)
* Beschwingte Popmusik *
* Zaghafte Klänge *
(Wie geht man
mit dem Älterwerden um?)
(Wir müssen die ganze Zeit
damit umgehen.)
(Niemand in einem normalen Job muss
derart oft vor dem Spiegel sitzen
und seine Falten wegschminken.)
(Das führt dazu,
dass man die Angst davor verliert.)
Es sind Aficionados.
- Menschen aus Paris.
Im Ernst.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mein Regisseur föhnt mir immer
vor der Vorstellung den Hintern.
* Ruhige Musik
übertönt das Gespräch. *
(Humor ist das Wichtigste,
glaube ich.)
(Für mich ist es etwas Zentrales.)
(Der Humor ist eine Art Lebensader.)
Das sage ich hier jetzt ganz ernst.
Was ist das?
- Ein DDR-Zünder. Ein echter.
Ein was?
- Ein richtiger DDR-Zünder.
Den brauchten sie
im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Da gab es die DDR noch nicht.
- Darum ist der bei uns.
* Lachen im Publikum *
Ist das sicher?
Absolut sicher,
dass es den Leuten gefällt.
Das braucht richtig Mut.
Das ist gefährlich.
- Und wie.
Ich bin froh, dass du das machst.
* Rockmusik:
"The Final Countdown" von Europe *
Bravo!
* Jubel *
(Ich muss lernen, dort im Leben
durchzugehen, wo es mir gut geht.)
(Wenn mir etwas guttut,
bleibe ich dran.)
(Das Spielen hat mir gutgetan.
Und ich bin drangeblieben.)
(Wenn ich den schlechten Sachen
oder den Krisen, die es auch gab,
die grosse Macht geben würde,
würde ich daran kaputtgehen.)
Oh. Applaus!
Danke schön.
Sag einfach ...
Ja.
Sie sind einfach ruhig heute.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Wir werden immer unsicher,
wenn sie ruhig sind.
Alles gut.
Wir als Schauspieler müssen manchmal
unsere Emotionen, die schmerzen,
draussen lassen - das ist der Deal.
Aber sie sind nachher wieder da.
Sie warten in der Garderobe.
Manchmal sind sie auf der Bühne.
Dann muss man sie wegschicken.
The winner is ...
... Ursus & Nadeschkin.
* Harte, rockige Musik
übertönt alles Gesagte *
* Tangomusik *
# All the dancers
may be on the floor.
# But my eyes will see only you.
(Tom sagt es häufig.)
(Wenn zwei Leute auf der Bühne sind,
Frau und Mann ...)
(90 % der Leute denken
die halbe Zeit nur darüber nach:
"Haben die was zusammen?"
Das ist doch absurd.)
* Beschwingte Musik *
(Bei Mann-Mann
ist es heutzutage auch schon so,
dass man sich fragt,
ob sie schwul sind.)
(Aber Frau-Mann
müssen einfach ein Paar sein.)
(Es sind ja eine Frau und ein Mann.
Was sollen sie sonst sein?)
* Spannende Musik,
Klopfgeräusch, Scheibenklirren *
Die zwei am meisten gestellten
Fragen an euch sind:
"Sind wir ein Paar?"
- Und: "Sind die Haare echt?"
Was trägst du
für eine blöde Perücke?
Das sind deine Haare.
- Die sehen nicht so aus.
Trage ich eine solche Mütze?
- Nein. Aber such mal eine Perücke,
die aussieht wie deine Haare.
Sie hat so schöne Haare.
Das sollte man zeigen.
Ich zeige sie ja.
Die sind doch schön.
Wenn man das mal ganz zeigt ...
* Lachen im Publikum *
(Das mit den Haaren ...
Es war meine Entscheidung.)
Ich wollte den Beruf machen. Zu
100 %. Die Haare passten zur Figur.
(Im ersten Drittel der Jahre
war das wichtig.)
(Es war ein Statement.)
Ich habe mich rausgeputzt.
- Diese beiden hätte ich nicht ...
Das hat niemand gemerkt.
Also wirklich.
Das lebt wahrscheinlich noch.
Es hat
mit meinem Privatleben kollidiert.
Ich wollte privat privat sein
und nicht die Figur.
(Ich habe die Dreadlocks
abgeschnitten - 2006.)
(Meine Mama war eine schöne Frau.
Coiffeuse.)
(Irgendwann liess ich sie
nicht mehr an meine Haare.)
(Ich hatte Dreadlocks.)
(Als ich sie abgeschnitten habe,
hatte ich keine
gebleichten blonden Haare mehr,
sondern dunkle Haare.)
(Ich schaute in den Spiegel
und sah aus wie meine Mutter.)
(Das war in dem Moment
schwer zu ertragen.)
(Meine Mutter war so krank.)
(Wenn ich in den Spiegel schaue,
möchte ich keine kranke Frau sehen.)
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so schön wird.
Mit der Zeit schon,
aber gleich jetzt ...
"Seid ihr auch privat ein Paar?"
Die Frage mögt ihr sicher besonders.
Ja, total.
Die Frage bleibt immer aktuell.
Ich sage Ja, sie sagt Nein.
- Ja.
Als ich schwanger war, dachten alle,
er sei der Vater.
Ich habe
viele Gratulationskärtchen erhalten.
Brigitta Schrepfer, die Frau von Urs,
ist Choreografin,
zeitgenössische Tänzerin und Dozentin
an der Zürcher Hochschule der Künste.
Dass Urs mit Nadja eine
sehr intensive Arbeitsbeziehung hat,
ist für sie selbstverständlich.
((Brigitta) Die Frage, ob ich
neidisch oder eifersüchtig bin ...)
(Überhaupt nie.)
(Aber ich hatte auch nie
den Hauch eines Gefühls,
dass ich das müsste.)
(Das sind
zwei ganz verschiedene Welten.)
(Und es war immer klar, dass das mit
Nadja eine Arbeitsbeziehung ist.)
Ob das jetzt eine Frau ist,
ein Mann oder etwas anderes.
Das ist ...
Das hat nie eine Rolle gespielt.
Die Aussicht ist schön.
Gut, jetzt hat es Nebel.
Aber ohne Nebel ...
(Ich glaube wirklich: Durch
ihre lange gemeinsame Beziehung ...)
Eine Arbeitsbeziehung ist,
auf einer anderen Ebene,
gleich anspruchsvoll
wie eine Liebesbeziehung.
Sie üben ganz viel.
Vielleicht auch Sachen,
die mir auch wieder zugutekommen.
Bestimmt.
Du hast auch schon gesagt, wir beide
sollten etwas mehr streiten.
Da sagte ich,
das sei bei mir abgedeckt.
Genau.
- In meiner Arbeitsbeziehung.
Du verstehst mich nicht.
- Was?
Du verstehst mich nicht. Darum
habe ich die Beratung angefangen.
Die wir machen. Gemeinsam.
Davon weiss ich nichts.
Du bist auch nie dort.
Was willst du von mir?
Was soll ich sagen oder machen?
Ich zeige dir ein kurzes Stück,
an dem ich arbeite.
Mit Musik.
Ich möchte wissen, was es erzählt
oder welche Assoziationen es weckt.
* Verspielte Musik *
Ich finde es sehr anregend.
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
Man sieht einfach etwas darin.
Jetzt kommt eine ganz andere Musik.
Die kommt jetzt?
- Ja.
(Für mich wäre es schwierig,
mit jemandem zu sein,
der von 9-17 Uhr arbeitet.)
(Es ist ein grosser Vorteil,
wenn beide in einem freischaffenden
künstlerischen Beruf arbeiten.)
(Man muss sich oft nicht erklären.)
* Verspielte Musik *
(Manchmal steckt man
mitten in seinen Sachen.)
(Wir mussten uns
als Paar dort finden.)
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir uns Inseln schaffen,
um wirklich Zeit füreinander zu
haben, um sich fallen zu lassen.
Es wäre schön ...
Jetzt müsste der Wecker kommen.
(Für die Leute erscheint die Arbeit
einfach die 2 Std. auf der Bühne.)
Wir müssen vorher und nachher
nichts machen.
Das ist jeweils die Frage:
"Was macht ihr tagsüber?"
Das ist
"Perlen, Freaks & Special Guests".
Ein kleiner ...
- (Beide) ... Programmeinblick.
* Schrei, wilde Musik *
(Variete ist wie Zirkus.)
Also nicht Zirkus.
Wir machen keinen Zirkus.
* Zirkusmusik *
Wir machen nicht ...
Was ist jetzt los?
Moment. Hey!
Was soll das? Was ist los?
Stopp!
# Baby, baby, schubi-dubi-du.
(Wir haben schon
in den 90er-Jahren gemerkt,
dass es auch Spass macht,
ab und zu mit anderen Künstlern
auf der Bühne zu sein,
weil man sich inspirieren kann.)
# Baby, baby ...
(Wenn Leute sagen,
man könne es nicht kombinieren,
interessiert es uns am meisten.)
(Dort geht immer eine Tür auf.
Dort wird es bunt.)
Ein Feuer. Was heisst Feuer
auf Englisch? - Fire.
Fire. - Fire!
- Nein. Es ist nichts passiert.
Hört auf! Es ist nichts passiert.
Hallo.
- Hallo. Ganz ruhig.
Es ist nichts passiert.
- Mann.
Wo?
- Da.
(Ich habe Mist gebaut.)
(Ich bin auf die Schnauze gefallen.
Mit einem E-Bike.)
Hallo. Geht's gut?
(Ich war schlechter Laune,
stand unter Stress,
wollte den Kleinen abholen,
hatte zu viel Tempo.)
(Ein alter Mann auf dem Veloweg,
der mich beschimpfte.)
(Ich drehte mich um, wünschte ihm
einen schönen Tag, da fiel ich hin.)
(Ich stürzte auf den Beton.
Ich stand auf, blutete stark.)
(Die Handgelenke waren verstaucht,
alles war offen, das Knie offen.)
(Ich bildete mir ein,
es sei nichts.)
(Erst am Abend merkte ich,
dass etwas nicht gut war.)
Das muss man untersuchen,
röntgen und genau anschauen.
Es scheint mir ...
Es fühlt sich sehr seltsam an.
Lass locker!
Hast du es noch niemandem gezeigt?
- Nein.
Du musst es zeigen gehen.
Das musst du zuerst abklären.
Sorry.
- Scheisse.
(Ich würde mir nie anmassen,
zu sagen, dass wir etwas bewirken
oder verändern mit dem,
was wir machen.)
(Ich finde, rein global, welt-
politisch, gesellschaftlich gesehen
ist es total unwichtig,
was wir machen.)
(Aber das kann man letztlich
von fast allem sagen.)
(Ich möchte etwas machen,
das mir wichtig ist,
das mir etwas gibt, das mich
inspiriert und mir Freude macht.)
(Im Idealfall ist es auch eine
Inspiration oder Freude für andere.)
* Lockere Musik *
(Schon als Kind
habe ich mich gesträubt,
etwas vor anderen Leuten zu machen -
das war für mich der Horror.)
(Ich hatte, wenn überhaupt,
nur Nebenrollen im Schultheater.)
(Es war mir peinlich.
Ich wurde rot.)
(Geblieben ist, dass ich
immer noch totalen Horror habe,
wenn ich privat
vor einer Gruppe von Leuten stehe.)
(Das kann ich niemandem erklären.)
(Alle denken:
"Du machst das die ganze Zeit.")
(Aber es ist etwas anderes.)
(Bei der Arbeit
schlüpfe ich in eine Rolle.)
(Dann macht es Spass. Aber
wenn ich das privat machen muss ...
Das hängt wohl auch damit zusammen,
dass ich finde,
ich möchte nicht so wichtig sein,
dass mir 100 Leute zuhören müssen.
Es gibt Leute, die fragen sich,
was die silbernen Pfeile bedeuten.
Querflöte vor dem Fagott. Und
die runden Hauben sind übrigens ...
(Beide) Waldhörner.
- Das wissen wir.
Dann gehen wir weiter
im Beethoven-Fragenkatalog.
Gerne.
- Gut.
Wie heisst der Komponist der "5.
Symphonie" von Ludwig van Beethoven?
* Lachen im Publikum *
Beethoven. Ludwig.
- Van.
Nennen Sie andere Komponisten
aus Beethovens Umfeld.
Ah, klar. Kein Problem.
Beethoven hatten wir.
Äh ... Mozart war z.B. einer.
Beethoven ... ähm ... wir haben ...
Strauss. Genau.
Der war einer. Und dann war da ...
Streicher. Genau.
Pinsler. Nein.
Ah. Mahler.
Und einer hat viel getrunken.
Und der hatte ein kleines Baby.
Der war wohl Krippenleiter oder so.
Ah, nein. Er gibt dem Baby
den Schoppen ... Chopin!
* Lachen im Publikum *
# Everybody now ...
# Come on, let me hear you say.
(Das kommt sehr gut an.)
- (Extrem.)
Das ist ein Extremfisch.
Was soll ich tun?
- Küss ihn doch!
# I wanna be ... * Seufzen *
... kissed by you just you.
Der Wumms.
Es hat noch nicht gewummst.
* Trommelwirbel *
* Paukenschlag *
Voila.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Besonders, besonders, besonders ...
* Klirren *
Besonders, ja, uh, uh, uh, ah.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
* Motorengeräusche *
Achtung!
(Wir haben uns komplett verändert.)
(Wir haben viel kindlicher begonnen.
Logisch.)
(Wir waren zwar schräg,
aber wir waren auch sehr zahm.)
(Und auch ängstlich.
Oder unerfahren.)
(Und ein wenig schüchtern.)
(Sid ist mein Sohn.)
(Er ist acht Jahre alt,
kann sehr fröhlich sein.)
(Er ist sehr ehrlich, glaube ich.
Er ist eine ehrliche Haut.)
(Ich bin grosser Fan meines Jungen.)
Nadja musste ihre Hand inzwischen
einer Operation unterziehen.
Sie muss sie nun
während mehrerer Wochen schonen.
Du sagst oft:
"Geht's, Mama? Das sagst du oft."
Das finde ich super.
Manchmal hat er mich gestreichelt
und gesagt: "Armes Mami."
(Mein Sohn hat
vor ungefähr zwei Jahren gemerkt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.)
(Mit mir.)
(Er ist gekommen und hat gefragt:
"Mama, warum kennen dich alle?")
(Das hat ihn sehr interessiert.)
(Das hat ihn auch gestresst.)
(Wenn er in der Schule
etwas anstellt, wird gesagt:
"Ist ja klar bei dieser Mutter,
die Clown ist, dass er Mist baut.")
(Das hat ihn beschäftigt.
Es ist nicht toll für ihn.)
(Wenn man immer diejenige ist,
die die Regeln bricht,
ist es spannend,
zum Polizisten zu werden.)
Ich sage nun: "Schuhe ausziehen."
"Hände waschen. Nicht schmatzen."
Ich finde es lustig,
wenn jemand am Tisch schmatzt.
Aber ich muss ihm beibringen,
dass er es nicht macht.
Ich will nicht, dass Sie kommen.
Ich hätte aufgeräumt.
Das dürfen Sie nicht filmen.
Das ist ...
Gut. Wir machen die Homestory
später vielleicht noch mal.
Es ist gemein. Man muss
seinem eigenen Sohn beibringen,
dass er keinen Blödsinn macht,
während er zuschaut,
wie die Mutter Blödsinn macht.
Das ist nicht gerecht.
Ja. Das finde ich auch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist eine schöne Zeit,
wenn ich mit meinem Mami sein kann.
Und ... ich finde es schön,
dass ich oft ins Theater kann.
Aber manchmal ist es mir zu viel.
Dann möchte ich einfach zwei Monate
lang oder so nicht mehr ins Theater.
So blöd. Nächste Woche
wollte ich mit dir in den Zirkus.
Kommst du nicht mit?
- Doch.
Im Glarnerland
hat Urs einen Rückzugsort,
wo er die Berge geniessen
und konzentriert arbeiten kann.
(Die Leute fragen oft:
"Wo findet man die Inspiration?")
("Wie kommen die Ideen?")
(Das ist ein Mysteriosum,
das ich auch faszinierend finde.)
(Bei mir hängt es
ganz klar damit zusammen ...)
(Zeit und Raum -
diese beiden Dinge sind elementar.)
* Sanfte Musik *
(Das ist ein Projekt ...
Es ist ein Herzensprojekt von mir.)
(Ich arbeite sicher seit 20 Jahren
immer wieder daran.)
(Ich bin jetzt 50 Jahre alt.)
(Ich möchte die Idee
langsam zu einem Abschluss bringen.)
(Ich möchte ein Buch daraus machen.)
Ein Buch,
von dem ich aber noch nicht weiss,
ob es jemanden interessiert.
Ich zeige es auch niemandem.
Ich mache das Buch
jetzt aber fertig.
(Ich arbeite gerade
an einer kurzen Leiter.)
Man kann sie brauchen, wenn man
irgendwo raufsteigen möchte,
wo es nicht hoch ist.
Wollen wir die da vorne überholen?
Überholen wir sie?
* Lockere Musik *
(Das macht die Erziehung
sehr schwierig. Er hat viel Mut.)
(Er kennt keine Angst.)
(Da muss er noch
auf die Welt kommen.)
Mit vier Jahren stand er mit
Schwimmflügeln auf dem 5-m-Brett.
Da rief der Bademeister, das
dürfe man nicht mit Schwimmflügeln.
Da zog er die Schwimmflügel aus
und sprang.
Das ist ... Das ist er.
* Sie lacht. *
(Im Privatleben
lief nie alles normal.)
(Ich wuchs ohne Mutter auf.)
(Ich hatte zum Glück
eine tolle Tagesmutter.)
(Ich hatte tolle Lehrpersonen.)
(Bei vielen schwierigen Sachen
hatte ich viel Glück.)
* Lockere Musik *
(Als Kind wollte ich immer
gleich sein wie die anderen.)
(Aufgrund der Art,
wie wir aufgewachsen sind,
war ich aber nie ein Normalfall.)
(Immer
auf der anarchistischen Seite.)
(Mir hat niemand gesagt,
ich dürfe nicht aufs Dach.)
(Die Polizei kam
und holte mich runter.)
(Aber ich hatte niemanden, der mir
ein Pflaster aufs Bein klebte,
weil es blutete.)
* Sanfte, gefühlvolle Musik *
(Und dann, als ich mit Urs begann,
Ursus & Nadeschkin zu machen,
habe ich gemerkt, dass Anderssein
plötzlich kein Problem mehr war.)
(Es schlug in die andere Richtung.)
(Es ist ein Kapital.)
(Meine Mutter hatte Frühalzheimer.)
(Sie wusste lange nicht, was es ist.
Es begann bei ihr mit 48.)
(Das wäre bei mir
schon im zweiten Jahr.)
Als sie krank war,
gab es einen Moment,
in dem man verziehen hat.
Es stand nicht mehr zwischen uns,
dass sie uns nicht aufgezogen hat.
Sie hatte
kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr.
Sie hatte uns immer gefehlt.
Das hat man gespürt.
Unsere Mutter konnte uns
nicht einfach herzhaft umarmen.
In jeder Umarmung schwang mit,
dass sie wusste,
dass sie das viel zu wenig tat.
Da hinten ist ein Schiff.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Mein Papa ist noch da.)
(Er ist sehr stolz.)
(Er hat sehr
mit meiner Berufswahl gehadert.)
(Ich hätte idealerweise
auch Architektin werden sollen.)
(Das hat sich dann beruhigt,
als wir erste Preise gewannen.)
(Es ist lange her,
dass er gehadert hat.)
(Es ist schon länger klar,
dass es ein seriöser Job ist.)
(Er ist schon stolz.)
* Zaghafte, ruhige Klänge *
(Mein Vater
ist noch viel extremer als ich.)
(Das impliziert,
dass ich auch extrem bin.)
(Aber er ist ein Vorbild für mich
bezüglich Notieren,
Listen machen.)
(Aber er hat es
viel konsequenter gemacht.)
(Da merkte ich:
"Das ist nicht meins.")
Er könnte mir sicher sagen,
was am 17. Mai 1956 für Wetter war.
Er hat es jeden Tag aufgeschrieben.
* Kuhglockenbimmeln *
(Ich mache es etwas chaotischer.)
(Mal ja, mal freestyle, dann wieder
improvisiert, dann wieder genau.)
(Dieses Hin und Her
zwischen Chaos und Ordnung
war mir schon immer am liebsten -
ich konnte mich nie entscheiden.)
(Ich bin gutbürgerlich behütet
aufgewachsen.)
(Wir waren vier Kinder.)
(Alle vier haben eigene,
sehr unübliche Wege eingeschlagen.)
(Ich bin der Jüngste
und hatte mehr Freiheiten.)
(Es war meinen Eltern
schnell klar, dass ich nicht ...)
(Ich habe eine Lehre
als Schriftsetzer gemacht.)
(Sie merkten schnell, dass das
nicht mein Lebensinhalt sein wird.)
Sie merkten,
dass ich etwas sperrig bin.
Sie gingen aber cool damit um.
Sie sagten immer:
"Uns ist wichtig,
dass du das machst,
was dir Freude macht."
"Aber wenn du das machst,
dann mach das wirklich."
Das fand ich grossartig.
Das rechne ich ihnen hoch an.
Daran denke ich oft.
Die Eltern haben ihren Sohn
auch dann unterstützt,
als er 1990 für sieben Monate
ins Gefängnis musste,
weil er den Militärdienst
verweigert hatte.
Wegen guter Führung wurde er bereits
nach fünfeinhalb Monaten entlassen.
(Mann) Unterhemd, Unterhose, ein
paar Socken, ein Rollkragenpullover
und ein Gurt.
(Wenn man im Militär überleben will,
muss man am besten
alles einfach machen.)
(Einfach machen, ohne zu denken.)
(Militär ist nicht ... Mensch.)
(Das Militär ist ein Ding.)
(Man ist immer
ein Schäfchen in dieser Herde.)
(Ich habe für mich das Gefühl,
dass man keinen Krieg bekämpfen kann
mit wieder einem Krieg oder so was.)
Wenn ich in dem Betrieb
funktionieren würde,
wäre ich eine Maschine.
Ich habe sogar das Gefühl,
sie hätten es geschafft.
* Der Motor startet. *
Daher ... Das Verhältnis
zum Staat oder zum Recht
ist für mich sehr fragwürdig.
* Sie spielen Beethovens
"5. Sinfonie" an. *
* Lang anhaltender Ton *
Okay. Gut.
* Sie spielen den Ton weiter. *
Es reicht.
- Jetzt haben wir den Mist.
* Alle spielen wirr durcheinander.*
* Die Musik stoppt. *
Ich möchte einen Blick
hinter die Kulisse werfen.
Ähm ...
Ich ... Ja, das können wir dann ...
(Unser Publikum
sieht uns ja nur auf der Bühne.)
(Die Zuschauer
machen häufig den Fehler, zu denken:
"Das ist diese Person,
die ich von der Bühne kenne.")
("Das ist Nadeschkin.
Das ist Ursus.")
(Das ist nicht so. Aber die Leute
können das nicht wissen.)
Privat bin ich sehr überlegt
und vorausschauend.
Häufig habe ich den Überblick,
die Übersicht.
(Ich sehe Zusammenhänge.)
(Auf der Bühne
bin ich kurzsichtiger.)
(Und auch gutgläubiger.)
(Und naiver. Und direkter.)
(Frecher. Gemeiner.)
(Es ist ganz anders.)
Du-ba-da-ba-dip.
A-di-ba-da-ba-dup.
A-ri-gä-di-gä-du.
Ä-düg. Ä-hüp. Ä-hüp-düp-düp.
Oh, ein Seil.
Nicht lustig?
- Nein.
Diejenigen unter Ihnen, die kein
Tattoo haben, gehen auf die Bühne
und erklären, warum.
Siehst du? Nur du stehst da und
erklärst, warum du keines willst.
(Nadeschkin ist viel weniger
reflektiert, hat weniger Angst.)
(Nadeschkin
ist viel anarchistischer.)
(Sie nimmt keine Rücksicht.)
(Sie fällt mit der Tür ins ...
Da kommt das ganze Haus rein.)
(Das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe viel mehr Respekt.)
(Ich, Nadja, bin ganz anders.)
Nadeschkin
hat ein paar Eigenschaften,
die ich mir manchmal fürs Private
wünsche, dass ich sie mehr hätte.
Es ist ein Traum,
dass man unreflektiert
und immer fröhlich sein könnte.
Boah, die sind extrem. Oh, boah!
* Applaus, Jubel *
* Jubel *
Boah!
Yeah.
Ein Hai klebt am Baum. Warum?
Uhu.
Ich finde es total paradox.
Es steht UHU drauf.
Aber es ist ein "Tuube" drin.
* Lachen *
Sie ist manchmal etwas vergesslich.
Seit wann?
- Das weiss sie auch nicht mehr.
Mist. Ich habe etwas vergessen.
Ah.
An vieles hast du ja schon gedacht.
Ja, das vergesse ich nicht. Aber was
ich vergesse, vergesse ich immer.
(Wir suchen überall im Leben
nach Themen für die Bühne.)
(Es hat mich geprägt, dass sich
meine Mutter im Kopf langsam
von dieser Welt verabschiedet hat.)
Was ist es denn?
- Weiss ich nicht mehr.
Darum habe ich nicht lange gesucht.
Du hast vergessen,
was du vergessen hast?
Ja. Ist aber nicht schlimm. Das
passiert oft. Ich bin daran gewöhnt.
Wenn jemand Alzheimer hat, sieht
jemand ein Weinglas und weiss nicht,
dass es ein Weinglas ist.
"Das ist doch kein Weinglas."
Dann tippt man aufs Weinglas.
Und durch den Klang, durch
das Geräusch, weiss die Person:
"Ah, es ist ein Weinglas."
Denn dieser Kanal funktioniert noch.
Erbsen wären super. In so
einem Moment bräuchte man Erbsen.
Ich sollte Erbsen haben.
Aber ich habe keine. Verdammt!
Ich hole meine Brille.
(Und diese Freude, wenn wieder
ein Wort im Kopf verankert ist.)
(Das habe ich oft gesehen.)
(Das spiele ich auf der Bühne.)
Das heisst Linsen, nicht Erbsen.
* Lachen im Publikum *
Du musst mehr Zug haben.
Wenn du so machst,
hast du mehr Druck drauf.
Dann wird es nur schlechter.
Die Heilung dauert länger als
erhofft, was Nadja sehr belastet.
Wie lange habe ich Zeit?
Ich würde die Hand
gerne etwas dehnen.
Das musst du nicht.
Es dauert etwa ein Jahr,
bis es wieder ist wie vorher.
(Ich habe hier
die Empfindung verloren
oder immer noch
ein gestörtes Empfinden.)
(In meinem Fall ist es das zweite
Kommunikationsmittel auf der Bühne.)
(Im Sommer hatte ich das Gefühl,
wenn es nicht besser wird,
werde ich nicht mehr lange spielen.)
Letzthin wurde mir bewusst,
wieso es "Patient" heisst.
Stimmt.
Das ist mir nie aufgefallen.
Aber ... Patient.
* Er brummt. *
(Ich hatte
einen Bandscheibenvorfall.)
(Den ersten Bandscheibenvorfall
meines Lebens.)
(Vor fünf Wochen.)
(Mein Rücken
begann langsam zu schmerzen.)
(Ein Schmerz, den ich schon kannte.)
(Ich dachte,
ich kriege das wieder hin.)
(Aber dann begann es,
stark zu schmerzen.)
(Ich ging zum Chiropraktiker.)
(Auf dem MRI sah man dann, dass es
ein Bandscheibenvorfall war.)
(Manchmal trage ich eine Stütze.)
Ich mache viele Übungen.
Ich kann alle Bewegungen machen,
bin aber noch sehr verunsichert.
* Sanfte, klare Musik *
Die Organisation
von Beruf und Familie
ist für freiberufliche Künstlerinnen
und Künstler nicht einfach.
Trotzdem nehmen sich Urs und Brigitta
nach Möglichkeit Zeit
für gegenseitiges Feedback.
((Brigitta) Es war natürlich schön,
dass wir zu zweit lange üben
konnten, bevor Jodok dazukam.)
Es ist so ...
* Sie blubbert und brabbelt. *
(Das hat sicher viel gebracht.)
(Für die Organisation der Familie,
die sehr anspruchsvoll ist.)
Es ist ein schöner Schluss.
Aber für sie ist ganz wichtig,
dass sie ...
... es den Leuten sagen will.
(Unser Sohn hat
das geregelte Leben eingebracht.)
(Die Schulzeiten sind immer gleich.)
(Wir mussten Wochenpläne machen
mit unseren Projekten und sehr
unregelmässigen Arbeitszeiten.)
(Ist das Kind klein,
muss man jede Stunde abdecken.)
Dann kommt irgendwann die Phase,
in der er auch mal
1 Std. alleine sein kann.
Mittlerweile ist er sogar froh, wenn
wir nicht da sind - einige Stunden.
* Musik, Stimmengewirr *
(Heute Abend ist die Loftparty.)
(Das ist etwas,
was ich seit 15 Jahren mache.)
(Wir hatten
schon über 60 solche Partys hier.)
Ich habe damit angefangen,
weil dieser Raum so gut tönt.
* Wassertropfgeräusch mit Echo *
Ein total schönes Echo.
Ich fand es eine Frechheit, dass ich
alleine eine so grosse Wohnung habe.
Ich wollte das teilen.
* Gemütliche Musik *
* Mitreissende Swingmusik *
(Es ist für mich
eine grosse Energiequelle.)
(So verliere ich
den Kontakt zur Aussenwelt nicht.)
(Es gibt viele Männer, die humor-
volle Frauen an ihrer Seite wollen.)
Es ist zwar Schubladendenken,
hat aber etwas Wahres.
Die Meinung ist nicht,
dass die Frau Humor haben soll.
Sie soll nur genug Humor haben,
um bei seinen Witzen zu lachen.
* Mitreissende Swingmusik *
(Es ist schwierig -
Augenhöhe in einer Beziehung,
wenn ich nach Hause komme
und Erfolg habe.)
Das ist nicht einfach
für einen Partner an meiner Seite.
Leider. Ich wusste lange nicht,
dass das so war. Aber es ist so.
Leider.
"Melodien, Menschen,
mild, mit, mit."
"Mond, Nacht, Nebel, Glanz."
"Nicht, nicht, nimmer, oder, oder."
Urs zeigt sein Soloprogramm
"Kunst aufräumen" in Braunwald.
Heute sind auch Frau Brigitta
und Sohn Jodok im Publikum mit dabei.
Das BSINTI
veranstaltet immer wieder Lesungen.
Leute lesen hier.
Ich bin der Autor
des Buchs "Kunst aufräumen".
Bettina hat mich gefragt, ob ich
eine Lesung daraus machen könnte.
Ich war schon zweimal hier,
und du weisst immer noch nicht:
Es ist ein Bilderbuch.
Ja.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
wie ich das machen könnte.
Ich habe für Sie Bilder auf Dias
kopiert. Ich möchte die Dias zeigen.
* Lachen *
Sie können sie vielleicht rumgeben.
Wir kommen zu meinem Lieblingsbild.
Rene Magritte aufräumen.
Das macht total Spass.
Man kann einfach ... So.
Oder man kann auch
in die Objektkunst gehen.
Die "Pelztasse" von Meret Oppenheim
habe ich in den Ursprungszustand
zurückversetzt.
Ich bin ja Familienvater.
Ich habe einen kleinen Sohn.
Gut, er ist nicht mehr klein.
Auf dieser Aufnahme
ist er noch kleiner.
Wir gehen oft auf den Spielplatz.
Er spielt jeweils im Sandkasten.
Bevor wir nach Hause gehen, sage ich
ihm, er soll alles aufräumen.
Ja.
Es ist komisch. In letzter Zeit will
er nicht mehr auf den Spielplatz.
Manchmal essen wir auch
Pommes Frites bei einem Take-away.
Aber mir ist wichtig, dass wir
immer wissen, wie viele es sind.
* Lachen *
(Ich habe von zu Hause ein Grund-
vertrauen ins Leben mitbekommen.)
(Der Glaube daran, dass der Weg,
den es nimmt, in Ordnung ist.)
(Dass es schon gut kommt. Oder
es muss nicht unbedingt gut kommen.)
(Es kann auch mal nicht so gut sein.
Das ist auch in Ordnung.)
Ich schreibe "Para".
Ja, "Para Besame". Genau.
P-a-r-a Besame.
Hast du es noch gekannt?
- Ja.
Aber da war auch viel Neues.
- Wirklich? - Ja.
Einige Braunwald-Sachen.
- Ja. Es hat mir gefallen.
(Das Urvertrauen
oder das Grundvertrauen
habe ich
von meiner Familie mitbekommen.)
(Ich hoffe, dass ich das
Jodok weitergeben kann -
gemeinsam mit Brigitta.)
Grossartig. Und auch einfach
nichts sagen und irgendwann ...
Jodok hat irgendwann gesagt: "Urs
macht so tolle, smoothe Übergänge."
Ganz schön.
- Das ist auch so.
Vielen Dank.
* Rasante Swingmusik *
# ... bella, bella.
# Even say wunderbar.
# Each language only helps me
tell you how grand you are.
* Leichte Jazzmusik *
Ich habe zwei, drei Themen.
Eines ist
der provisorische Tourneeplan.
Da müssen wir
ein paar Sachen anschauen.
Am Sonntag, 22.8.:
Einrichten in Baden.
Wir sprechen von 2021?
- Ja, 2021.
(In diesem Job denkt man nicht
an die nächsten zehn Jahre,
sondern an die nächsten Projekte und
du musst v.a. im Moment gut sein.)
(Du musst jetzt
fröhlich oder lustig sein.)
Das ist erst 2021.
Das ist noch viel zu früh.
So.
Ich habe dieses hier.
- Das ist aber schön.
Pferde sind noch nicht verboten.
- Nein.
Die Perücke noch. - Darfst du
da reinsteigen mit deinem Arm?
Ich probiere es.
Es hält ja nicht am Arm. Den
Rucksack konnte ich auch anziehen.
So.
Ho.
* Flinke Zirkusmusik *
Stopp! Stopp!
Stopp!
Ah!
- Stopp!
Hör auf!
Ho, ho.
* Die Musik stoppt. *
Ho.
Super, das hast du jetzt davon.
Meine Güte, ist das peinlich.
- Ho.
Entschuldigung, Sie.
Der ist mir voll durchgebrannt.
War ich da nicht mal ganz drin?
Bin ich dicker geworden
oder grösser?
Du bist v.a.
von weit her reingesprungen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist schwierig, Urs.
Du hast einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Soll ich es probieren?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Hast du das mit
der Physiotherapeutin abgesprochen?
Super.
Das geht dann schon. Im Sägemehl.
Achtung, Nadja.
Ein gefährlicher Move.
Nadja.
- Hä?
Die Finger.
- Verdammt schwer. Rücken.
Ja, sie sind recht schwer.
Nadja, mach das nicht.
- Okay.
Es sieht eben schön aus.
Die Leute würden garantiert
die Füsse zurückziehen.
Auf dem Rand habe ich Angst.
Aber ich muss es mal probieren.
Wo?
Oh, da ist eine Delle.
Es geht schon.
Es ist etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Man darf überhaupt nicht umfallen.
2002 gastierten Ursus & Nadeschkin
im Circus Knie.
Fast 18 Jahre haben sie gezögert,
die Manege noch einmal zu betreten.
Die Bedenken waren gross und sind
auch jetzt noch nicht ganz vom Tisch.
Trotzdem wagen sie sich dieses Jahr
in die zweite Runde
des Zirkusabenteuers.
Oh. Das ist verdammt anstrengend.
Das wird anstrengend, ja.
Zum Glück
ist meine linke Hand verletzt.
Es ist verrückt: Vor einem Jahr
waren wir in Schottland.
Vor 28 Leuten, jeden Tag.
Und jetzt arbeiten wir wieder
an einem Programm,
bei dem man pro Tag
ein- bis zweimal 2'300 Leute hat.
* Knall *
* Kein Knall *
Wenn ich so mache,
im richtigen Moment "autsch" rufen.
Autsch.
* Knall *
Oh!
Die lange Peitsche
ist nichts für uns.
(Es war damals schon schwierig.)
(So schön Zirkus war,
irgendwann waren beide ...
Wir hatten Verbrennungen.
- Ihr wart regelmässig am Arsch.
Es ist immer schlimm, wenn man
verletzt oder krank auf Tour ist.
Aber im Zirkus ist es potenziert.
Es ist jeden Tag und hört nicht auf.
Man kann nicht ausruhen.
Mit Hexenschuss hat man nicht frei.
Manchmal zweimal am Tag.
- Das ist ... Können wir das noch?
* Verspielte, ruhige Musik *
Hoi.
- Hey.
(Es ist Anfang Dezember.)
(Heute ist Premiere.)
(Wir sind in Winterthur.)
(Wir begannen im September
mit Try-outs und Testvorstellungen.)
(Heute ist es die 19. Vorstellung.)
(Und die heisst heute Abend
Premiere.)
Wir tun, als wäre es ...
Es ist viel passiert.
Das Stück hat sich sehr verändert.
Es atmet ganz anders.
Aber ob es bereit ist ...
Wir kommen aber auch auf die Welt
und können noch nicht laufen.
Heute kommt das Stück zur Welt.
- Hm. - Hm.
Also ... Also das ...
Und dann stelle ich mir vor,
ich schliesse das Fenster. Wumm!
Alles weg. Gut.
* Popmusik *
Für ihr neues Programm
haben Ursus & Nadeschkin
mit verschiedenen Tanzlehrern
gearbeitet.
Vor der grossen Premiere:
ein letzter Probedurchgang mit
der Balletttänzerin Laura Atwood.
* Zauberhaft sanfte Walzermusik *
And in.
Oh, I love that tune.
Ah.
Von "Amelie", nicht?
- Ja.
And out. Bend the knees.
* Sie atmet geräuschvoll aus. *
We go to the side
with the right foot.
Going out and in.
(Ich mache die Leute
gerne fröhlich.)
(Natürlich ist es auch
eine Selbstdarstellung.)
(Aber in meiner Empfindung ist
die Selbstdarstellung weit hinten.)
(Ich freue mich,
wenn die Leute Freude haben.)
(Das Publikum kommt mit
schönen Erwartungen, mit Freude.)
(Wenn es mir nicht gut geht,
kann ich auf der Bühne einsammeln,
was sie mir
an Energie entgegenschicken.)
(Mit dieser Energie arbeite ich. Ich
muss nicht alles aus mir nehmen.)
Side.
Feel the book on your head.
Tea cups on your shoulders.
* Leise, leicht hektische Musik *
(Wir hatten ungefähr
3'000 Vorstellungen,
seit wir begonnen haben.)
(Wenn man dasselbe Programm
jede Woche im selben Theater spielt,
kommt man in einen Trott.)
(Das wäre der Horror.
Wir machen etwas ganz anderes.)
(Wir haben
viele verschiedene Programme,
sind immer an anderen Orten.)
Hey. Macht's gut.
- Comment tu-vas, tu-tu?
Toll. Ich freue mich.
Ja, du ... Wir uns auch.
- Komm schon. Ihr seid ja ...
Du weisst ja, wie es ist: Premiere.
- Ich weiss.
In diesem Buch habe ich
ein Zitat von Dimitri gelesen.
Dimitri hat gesagt:
"Wenn man die schlechteste Vor-
stellung eines Clowns sehen möchte,
muss man an die Premiere gehen."
Da dachte ich: Ja, genau.
* Hektische Musik *
(Wir sind ein sehr starkes Team.
Gemeinsam.)
(Wir ergänzen uns sehr gut.)
(Wir wussten von Beginn an,
dass wir nicht zusammenpassen.)
(Wir hatten aber immer Lust,
genau das eben doch auszuprobieren.)
(Es war uns immer genügend wichtig,
dass wir
als Team weitergehen wollten.)
(Wir sind wie Geschwister,
haben eine sehr enge Verbundenheit.)
(Manchmal sind wir auch
weit voneinander entfernt,
was in Ordnung ist.)
(Manchmal verstehen wir uns
überhaupt nicht. Auch in Ordnung.)
(Das spricht auch
für diese Freundschaft.)
(Das kann man
in einer dicken Freundschaft.)
Let vaterä hüne. Ah.
- (Alle) E predentesi.
Tene vesna. Ot löwi.
En trösnö. Franzöndö begindö gös.
Öken. Häven höd öja ödehüd.
Öja ödehüd. Verklava.
Öken. Meldä grössna de göi.
Alta trüi sinte geda.
Chavre nessna fröri.
Erö-törö-törö.
Törö-törö-törö. Okay. Regulirtä.
Tack sa mycket.
* Stimmengewirr aus dem Saal *
Das wird schön.
* Pfiffige,
erwartungsvolle Klaviermusik *
* Applaus *
(Beide, im Rhythmus der Musik)
# Sehr verehrte Damen und Herren.
# Schön sind Sie alle da.
# Grüezi mitenand.
(Wir sind alle abhängig davon,
dass wir mit unserem Beruf -
egal, welchen Beruf wir ausüben -
etwas Sinnvolles machen wollen.)
(Wenn die Leute keine Freude
an dem haben, was wir machen,
ist es absolut sinnlos.)
(Dann möchte ich das nicht machen.)
(Wir haben irgendwann gemerkt,
dass es schon viele Momente
zum Aufhören gab.)
(Aber wir hatten immer das Gefühl,
Aufhören sei einfach.)
(Aufhören kann man immer.)
(Diese Option haben wir immer.
Diese Tür steht immer offen.)
(Aber es ist nicht so interessant.)
# Sie werden denken, was tun die da
um Himmels Gotts Willen.
# Das schaffen die nie da.
# Ballett ist noch schwierig,
das hätten wir nie gedacht.
# Leute sagen,
es sei ungesund fürs Kniegelenk.
(Uns interessiert,
wie es sonst noch weitergehen könnte
ausser durch die Tür,
die zum Ausgang führt.)
* Verspielte Streichmusik *
(Das andere ist: Wir befürchten,
dass wir noch im Altersheim
gemeinsam auftreten,
weil es nie eine Gelegenheit gab,
sich wirklich zu trennen.)
* Applaus, Jubel *
So süss.
Ein so süsses Mikrofon.
- Ja.
Bist du auch dabei?
- Auch in Schottland?
Immer dabei.
Magst du deine Kamera so gerne?
Wo ist die Kamera?
- Wo? Da drüben, nicht wahr?
Wir haben
stundenweise Garderobenmaterial.
Ich glaube, das gibt einen Film,
der "Die Garderobe" heisst.
Hm!
Sorry.
* Sie trällern. *
* Beide lachen. *
Interessant ist: Wir sprachen davon,
dass wir alte Säcke seien.
Aber wenn ich den hier sehe ...
Alle sagen mir, ich sähe jung aus,
wenn ich in der Manege sei.
* Er stöhnt, sie lacht. *
- Jetzt ist das Mikrofon weg.
Sägemehl im Mikrofon ist nicht gut.
Wenn du das kannst ... Geh mal weg!
Ich kann das auch.
Achtung.
* Schallendes Lachen *
Wie nennt man das?
- Wir sind alleine im Proberaum.
* Gemächliche Musik *